it took several hours to reveal the road
which leads up to the river horse
industrial estate
with members of several community groups
providing the people
and the power but this is a cleanup job
of
gigantic proportions what did you think
when you
uh when you first saw this place
it looked like a scene from a zombie
movie yeah it looked like a scene from
one of those epic in the world movies
these warehouses in durban were looted
and burnt
in a bout of violence that has stunned
south africa
although the government says the
situation is now moving towards
stability
yet the looting continues in a slightly
less frenetic
fashion how's the cleanup going
as you can see there's a lot of poor
people in our country
those are people that are obviously
below the working class those are the
poor there's
large quantities of them as they say
they're hungry
and this has just shown us how hungry
and desperate they are
that desperation now extends to the
entire city
which has become a community of queues
guys you're not going to get a chance to
shop in the suburb of um
thousands stood in line for the local
supermarket
but the shop would only let 300 in
we've been up and down this road couple
of times telling them if you get a
ticket you're going to go in if you
don't get a ticket you can't shop
what sort of reaction are you getting
some of them understand some of them
don't understand
food medicine and fuel are difficult to
get
as businesses assess their losses what
would you say to the
to the looters if you could you know
there's all these people are standing
here they want food that's all we want
we just want to get some groceries
some stuff some sustainability for homes
you know what i mean so
yeah i don't know i don't have words for
the looters i don't have words for the
looters
uncertainty is something that everyone
shares
in the predominantly asian district of
phoenix
locals man roadblocks armed with
machetes or
golf clubs after a week of violence here
that's left at least 20 dead i wouldn't
say
we're taking the law into our own hands
i mean if there is no
law to protect us what do we do
the cost to this city is difficult to
calculate
and everyone knows it could happen again
john sparks sky news in durban